[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques secondes plus tard tout juste
avant l'arrestation de la Saillon on
voit dans une autre vidéo que deux
témoins tentent de stopper l'homme qui
brandit son couteau regardez
[Musique]
4 minutes après le premier appel à
police secours la saillant est
interpellé par plusieurs policiers un
homme a filmé la scène regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a vu on a vu toutes les images on
aimerait que vous nous raconter
exactement ce qui s'est passé après on
aura les témoignages exclusives de les
audio de Johan commerçants et on lira la
lettre d'Anthony le telec principal
témoin qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ce matin c'est des petits enfants qui
ont été sauvagement attaqués par un
individu un individu qui avait déjà été
remarqué repéré depuis plusieurs jours
vous allez en parler
à 9h45 un petit peu avant 9h45
cet homme est rentré donc dans le cadre
à proximité du lac d'Annecy dans un
jardin du lac il y a une aire de jeux
pour les enfants qui est pas très grande
elle fait 15 mètres par 15 mètres
environ et cet individu on l'a vu
d'ailleurs sur les sur les images
a agressé alors il cherchait ses
victimes c'était que des enfants des
petits-enfants dans des poussettes à un
moment il y a une scène où une personne
d'un certain âge qui devait être la
grand-mère essayer de protéger sa petite
fille ou son petit-fils et l'individu de
la bousculé pour aller poignarder
l'enfant dans la poussette et ensuite il
a cherché on le voit aéré comme ça mais
en fait il cherche des cibles ils
cherchent des victimes et il a poignardé
quatre enfants des enfants très jeunes
très des bébés ça va de 22 mois 22 mois
deux ans trois ans et un autre un petit
peu plus âgé mais on est entre entre 22
mois et 3 ans et demi
il a eu deux adultes également été
blessés et il y a 78 ans qui a reçu une
balle perdue au moment de la
terrepellation de la saillance
oui alors dans un deuxième temps il a
effectivement agressé un adulte et puis
et puis un autre un monsieur de 70 ans
et c'est à ce moment-là que les
policiers sont intervenus mais il
n'arrivait pas à le maîtriser et ils ont
été à un moment donné obligés d'ouvrir
le feu justement alors est-ce que c'est
ça on entend dans la vidéo
des personnes dire tiens
il y a certaines personnes il a vu des
témoignages aujourd'hui certaines
personnes qui disait qu'ils ont mis du
temps à attirer sur la saillant et que à
un moment c'est vrai qu'il s'attaquait
justement à cette à cette ce monsieur de
78 ans voilà que ils étaient un peu ils
disaient est-ce que voilà est-ce que ça
prend un peu tarder mais je crois que
c'est il pouvait pas je pense que il
faut être en situation pour savoir ce
qu'on doit faire sont des policiers
c'est pas des des policiers du Raid
c'est policiers de sécurité publique ils
ont une arme ils ont un petit
entraînement au tir mais font pas partie
ni du règne ni d'abeille et tirer comme
ça sur un individu je pense que ça doit
être très compliqué sachant qu'en plus
ils ont souvent des ennuis une fois
qu'ils vont ces usage de leurs armes
et ils sont entendus à l'IGPN et de
temps en temps ils ont des sanctions
administratives parce qu'on va toujours
leur dire le couteau c'était la défense
était pas proportionnelle
c'est à dire que maintenant je pense que
le policier au moment où il arrive sur
cette scène il a son arme à la main il
se dit bon si je tire est-ce que je vais
pas avoir des emmerdes et c'est
peut-être la fraction de seconde de trop
qui fait que et alors c'est c'est
incroyable la police intervenu
rapidement comment vont les enfants
alors on parle Gilles ou peut-être des
infos ils sont en urgence absolue c'est
à dire que ils ont été opérés pour les
les quatre enfants mais il y a encore un
pronostic vital qui n'est pas levé à
l'heure où on parle là donc leur état de
santé préoccupant ils ont été gravement
blessés poignardées à l'arme blanche
donc un Opinel pliant mais c'est une
vraie lame une vraie arme blanche et
donc ils ont été poignardés pour être
tués donc l'enquête est ouverte pour
tentative d'assassinat alors est-ce
qu'on a des infos justement sur la
Saillon sur oui alors on sait qu'il
s'appelle Abdallah Annecy c'est un
Syrien il est né en 1991 il est arrivé
en Suède où il a demandé le statut de
réfugiés politiques qu'il a fini par
obtenir il a il était père de famille et
je pense que d'ailleurs tout le problème
il a un enfant de presque 3 ans je crois
que c'est c'est là le le lien d'ailleurs
avec les faits mais j'y revenir il était
donc marié père d'une petite fille de 3
ans
son couple a capoté il y a environ huit
mois et il a disparu des écrans radars
en tout cas de la Suède il y a quatre
mois où il est venu s'installer à Annecy
où il était à priori SDF
il me semble qu'il dormait dans une
église en tout cas ce qu'il a dit à sa
femme la dernière fois qu'il a eu au
téléphone il lui a dit qu'il dormait
dans une église
alors
vous avez dit on l'a dit il a lui-même
un enfant de presque trois ans et vous
dites que ça aurait pu c'est
passé ce matin si vous voulez l'enquête
démarre donc on va peut-être pas aller
plus vite qu'à la musique mais là depuis
ce matin j'entends tous les commentaires
avec mes confrères et accessoirement
certains politiques tout le monde veut
que ça soit un attentat terroriste bon
il se trouve que ce type est chrétien
priori en tout cas si on accepte de
croire ce qu'il raconte il avait une
croix autour du cou il avait un ouvrage
religieux chrétien dans son sac à dos
le parquet lui-même dit qu'il y a pas
d'éléments qui laissent à penser que
c'est un attentat terroriste donc
moi je je sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas de
certitude évidemment c'est une hypothèse
que je lance comme ça
son couple va mal il a cet enfant de
trois ans dont il est privé enfin en
tout cas il ne le voit plus à partir il
sépare et qui quittent la Suède
on sait qu'il venait tous les jours à
l'endroit où les les crimes ont été
perpétrées
c'est un endroit où il y avait beaucoup
d'enfants et tout le monde dit qu'il
était là si sur le banc du matin au soir
et ce qu'il a pas vrillé à un moment
donné en pensant à son enfant et de
toute façon son comportement n'est pas
logique enfin il y a pas de
c'est pas c'est pas il y a rien de
logique dans ce et y compris son
comportement pendant la garde à vue où
il se roule par terre et refuse de
s'expliquer alors Yohan qui est
commerciant qui est glacier et qui
travaille à proximité du lieu d'attaque
peut pas être avec nous ce soir car il
est encore sous le choc il a tenu à nous
laisser des messages il nous a dit qu'il
avait repéré l'homme et que dès le début
il a trouvé qu'il avait un comportement
plutôt étrange écoutez
alors il nous a également confié que son
nom lui ses actes étaient programmés car
l'homme rodé depuis plusieurs jours dans
le parc
S
[Musique]
il a attaqué des enfants de 3 ans
c'est important ce qu'il dit absolument
alors justement on regardait avec
Géraldine les dernières infos là il y a
quatre jours seulement cet homme avait
vu sa demande d'asile en France rejeté
quatre jours ce qui correspond peu au
proue à ce que Johan dit c'est à dire
que depuis quelques jours il rôdait
est-ce que dans sa tête pour le moment
il y a pas de mobile mais est-ce que
dans sa tête quand il a eu cette demande
d'asile refusée est-ce que quelque chose
a basculé peut-être on verra sachant
qu'il avait quitté la Suède pour venir
en France justement dans l'espoir lui
d'obtenir un titre de séjour plus
permanent peut-être donc est-ce qu'il y
a eu quelque chose qui a vrillé dans sa
tête à ce moment-là c'est ce que les
enquêteurs tentent de savoir
alors il a tenu également Yoann a
félicité la police qui sont lui ont fait
ont effectuer un travail exceptionnel
écouter
[Musique]
exemplaire
vraiment la police s'est fait un travail
incroyable nous avons pu lui mettre une
base de la tête ils auraient pu faire
n'importe quoi
et après
alors il y a Anthony Le Tallec grand
joueur de football qui était sur place
au moment des faits il a publié
plusieurs vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux
et nous a demandé de lire un communiqué
juste après regardez
au bord du lac et je vois tout d'un coup
dizaines de personnes qui courent dans
le sens contraire de moi et d'un coup il
y a une maman qui me dit courez courir
il y a quelqu'un qui poignard tout le
monde tout au long tout au long du lac
et moi c'est un peu surpris je continue
et je vois le mec effectivement qui
arrive en face de moi et sur l'herbe et
je vois des des flics qui sont à 5 10
mètres derrière lui qui arrive pas à
l'attraper il arrive vers moi donc je
m'écarte un peu et je vois qui qui fonce
tout droit sur des papiers et mamie et
là et là il attaque il attaque le papy
alors
dit aujourd'hui j'ai vécu la pire
journée de mon existence en étant
malheureusement témoin d'acte abominable
sur des victimes sans défense je
n'arrête pas de penser à ces familles de
toucher par ce drame dont les enfants et
la personne âgée qui sont en train de se
battre pour rester en vie au moment où
j'écris ce message ce matin j'ai frôlé
la mort de près en me retrouvant face à
un individu armé qui venait de commettre
l'irréparable alors que j'étais en état
de choc et révolté quelques minutes
après que le criminel a été neutralisé
par les forces de l'autre j'ai livré mon
témoignage à chaud aux médias avec
beaucoup d'émotions avec un immense
sentiment d'impuissance je me souligner
le fait que les policiers qui ont
poursuivi la saillant avec beaucoup de
courage on fait le maximum pour protéger
la population sur place je ne suis pas
policier pour vivre ce type de situation
et je ne veux en aucun cas remettre en
question leur courage et leur bonnes
volonté pour arrêter le criminel à
l'armée je souhaite vraiment que l'on se
soucie dorénavant de l'état de santé des
victimes pour lesquelles je prie et
insister sur la qualité de
l'intervention des policiers grâce
auxquels la liste des victimes de ces
paralongés j'ai décidé de m'exprimer ce
soir via ce message pour apporter tout
le monde soutien envers les victimes
leurs familles aux policiers ainsi que
les équipes médicales qui sont en train
de se battre pour sauver la vie de ces
innocents parce que c'est vrai qu'il a
fait un tém juste après Gilles c'est
formidable ce qu'il dit parce
qu'effectivement juste après c'est lui
que l'on entend sur la vidéo que vous
avez passé dire mais tirer son jogging
et il a il a vu son footing il a vu le
la saillant passé et puis il a vu la
course poursuite que vous montriez et à
ce moment-là ils disent mais pourquoi
vous ne tirez pas et là il s'est rendu
compte après c'est vrai que les
policiers avaient fait ce qu'il pouvait
dans un contexte que personne ne peut
imaginer d'une violence terrible aussi
aux policiers d'avoir mis un temps
infini pour intervenir ce qui est pas
vrai c'est pour ça qu'il a écrit ce ce
communiqué au bout de 4 minutes
aujourd'hui c'est la question qu'on pose
à chaque fois et c'est vrai qu'on dit à
chaque fois qu'on a des drames comme ça
est-ce qu'il aurait pu être évité
non non voilà un individu qui vient
qui vient de Suède en fait qui vient de
Syrie d'abord qui s'installe en Suède
qui obtient un statut de réfugié
politique en bonne et due forme il se
marie il a une petite fille de 3 ans il
est inconnu des services de police
inconnus de des services de
renseignement
il sépare avec sa femme il décide de
venir vivre en France
il était vaguement étudiant pour devenir
infirmier et il commet ce geste
terrifiant terrible non ça pouvait pas
être évité il y avait aucun moyen de
d'imaginer qu'il allait faire passer à
l'acte comme ça en 2013 et depuis 2013
il y avait pas de signalement auprès des
services de police
suédois visiblement du jour au lendemain
il vient là il donne plus de nouvelles à
sa femme et à son enfant en bas âge mais
effectivement il y a aucun signe pas
d'antécédent pas fichier s pas de délire
en France SDF et et Yoann dont vous avez
passé le témoignage déjà lui-même je le
voyais là mais c'est pas parce qu'on
voit quelqu'un même un peu agité avec un
sac à dos dans un square qu'on va
alerter sur le reproche mais il n'a pas
de raison qu'on ne peut rien faire ça
paraît pour là alors on parle ça paraît
imparable ce qu'il a fait alors le lieu
d'attaque se trouve juste à côté d'une
école des l'annonce de ce drame les
parents ont couru jusqu'au lieu des
faits afin de vérifier que leur enfant
allait bien regarder le témoignage de ce
de ce pas regarde
qu'ils étaient
à côté du papier ils étaient dehors dans
une classe dans une classe qui a lieu
tous les jeudis sur le jardin de
l'Europe à 59 donc j'ai couru pour
vérifier que tout allait bien et
j'ai eu peur également que
qu'il y a encore du danger pour les pour
les enfants et on m'a dit que non et
depuis j'attends et
je suis un peu ému par l'émotion et la
peur et l'émotion des autres parents
j'ai un qu'on revienne sur son statut de
réfugiés parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui réagissent dessus qui disent
qu'il s'agit d'une son statut de
réfugiés français a été refusé car il
avait déjà trois statues de réfugiés en
Italie en Espagne en Suède donc on peut
pas avoir autant de statues de réfugiés
et d'ailleurs love froid a refusé de de
le prendre parce qu'il au prétexte qu'il
était déjà
résidant suédois
donc
le débat qui se pose et à mon avis sur
les réseaux aussi c'est est-ce que c'est
parce que la Suède a accordé ou l'Italie
ou l'Espagne un visa donc c'est des
visages Schengen donc aujourd'hui on
peut circuler librement la question
qu'il faut se poser et elle est réelle
c'est est-ce que quand un autre pays
accorde un visage Schengen doit-on
continuer et ce sera le à mon avis un
des débats politiques doit-on continuer
autoriser librement l'accès voilà ça
c'est un vrai débat et il existe
aujourd'hui il y a libre accès des gens
certains partis politiques sont pour
refermer certaines frontières et ça je
pense qu'on peut pas esquiver la
question vu ce qui s'est passé voilà ça
viendra après mais en tout cas c'est un
débat ce sera un débat politique alors
aujourd'hui après son arrestation
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire voilà
est-ce que vous avez eu des policiers
est-ce que vous avez eu des personnes
qui ont témoigné alors la garde à vue
est en cours il y a un vrai problème
d'origine psychologique ou psychiatrique
il est je serai pas surpris que la garde
à vue soit suspendue pour des raisons
psychiatriques a priori d'après ce que
je sais il se roule par terre et il ne
répond à aucune question compte tenu des
faits qu'il vient de commettre
son paraît quand même un petit peu
dérangé
si la garde à vue suspendue
si les médecins la psychiatrie va le
prendre va le prendre en charge je vais
te soigner il peut éventuellement être
soigné dans un hôpital prison
après ça n'engage que moi ce que je suis
en train de dire là ça n'engage personne
ni aucun chroniqueur ni aucun personne
ni la chaîne ni Cyril ça n'engage que
moi c'est un chien et un chien
même un chien je préfère les chiens plus
d'amour même les chiens ne font pas ça
pour moi il est tout en bas de l'échelle
de l'humanité et certains vont te dire
faut le soigner faut le remettre debout
il faut le nourrir pendant 20 ans et
après à 60 ans 50 ans il va ressortira
toujours la même chose ce qui est pas
normal
c'est que je dis toujours la même chose
pour des affaires différentes c'est ça
qui est pas normal je devrais dire la
même chose pour une seule affaire mais
tous les 15 jours je dis toujours la
même chose pour une affaire différente
c'est qu'il y a bien c'est qu'il y a
bien un souci je pensais qu'il y a bien
un souci je suis d'accord avec vous on
pouvait pas on pouvait pas l'arrêter ça
on pouvait pas on pouvait pas le prévoir
ça je suis entièrement d'accord avec
vous sur les qualifications est-ce un
acte terroriste elle s'en aque un
accable pour moi pour moi c'est
terroriste de faire ça pour moi qui peu
importe parce qu'il avait une croix
parce que ces terroristes et pour moi ce
mec là j'ai un gros souci avec les gens
comme ça
en France
réfugié en France
on n'était pas la peine c'est ça
d'accord et donc ça veut dire que si
jamais il est incarcéré soit de manière
psychiatrique soit dans une prison c'est
à dire qu'il sera en France où on va le
rapatrie on va le renvoyer en Suède
par rapport au fait que ça demande a été
refusée en France les autorités
françaises ont justifié ça en disant il
n'en n'avait pas besoin
puisqu'il l'a on souhaite déjà et donc
il peut être là donc il n'était pas
illégalement en France
donc là pour les téléspectateurs qui
nous rejoignent à 21h10 après ce drame
donc là il est il est encore en garde à
vue oui il est en garde à vue jusqu'à
demain 48 heures enfin ça a commencé ce
matin au moment de l'interpellation la
garde à vue c'est immédiat est immédiate
donc j'ai envie de savoir qu'est-ce qui
peut sortir d'une garde à vue comme ça
il peut s'expliquer il peut à un moment
donné avoir le ressentir le besoin de de
de libérer sa conscience de de
s'effondreur on l'a déjà vu la même
manière qu'il aura un avocat
voilà s'assurer que tout se passe bien
dans les règles de droit
et il peut accessoirement lui dire de
garder le silence
où éventuellement lui de lui conseiller
de parler mais je pense que dans un cas
comme ça moi si j'étais avocat juillet
vas-y raconte explique-nous ce qui ce
qui était passé par la tête il parle
français ce monsieur
il a crié en fait au nom de Jésus-Christ
en anglais quand il a fait les quand il
a perpété tout à fait deux fois sans que
pour l'instant il faut bien le rappeler
sans que pour l'instant le parquet
national antiterroriste saisissent de
l'affaire donc pour le moment il y a pas
de mobile mais aucun mobile terroriste
n'a été retenu il faut dire ça parce que
certes il est chrétiens mais il y a
absolument aucun artiste qui est prévu
actuellement c'est qu'il est pas vu son
enfant depuis
oui c'est l'homme qui est là il fait
pour des tas de raisons euh
sans voir son enfant perd la tête et
comme un acte abominable ça n'excuse
rien du tout hein mais ça va poser la
question tout ça de la responsabilité ou
de l'irresponsabilité on voit bien que
son attitude en garde à vue est-ce que
c'est volontaire est-ce que c'est voilà
est-ce qu'il fait exprès il lui il va
tenter sans doute peut-être que ça se
termine par une irresponsabilité un coup
de folie une bouffer délire et là c'est
vraiment mille fois hélas
moi ça me rend dingue se pose la
question de la folie comme c'était une
circonstance atténuante pas la question
il faut être fou pour faire ça c'est un
fou comme ça on est fou en quoi ça va
atténuer la gravités
ça aussi ça aussi posé la question parce
que c'est de toute façon il est fou on
va dire que c'est normal qu'il soit fous
pas fou faut les enfermer on est
d'accord mais c'est peut-être pas la
peine de d'enfermer des fous en prison
parce que d'abord ça fait prendre des
risques aux autres détenus et puis les
fous si on peut accessoirement les
soigner c'est pas plus mal quoi il
fallait criminels en voyant ça ils vont
se dire je de la folie à chaque fois
quand
ça marche pas forcément
pas arrivés par le dernier TGV et ils
savent déceler si le type est dingue
complètement au sens médical du terme
c'est si il est fou ou non il y en a
plein qui essaient de se faire passer
pour des fous c'est un sport national de
se faire passer pour un fou moi j'avais
un vieux voyou qui
avait un jour il était convoqué il
voulait se faire passer pour un fou et
depuis 8 jours il était à quatre pattes
dans sa cellule et il aboyait il mordait
les matons et le juge la convoqué
et lorsqu'il est arrivé dans le bureau
du juge il a
uriné sur le bureau du juge
bon il s'est fait expulser évidemment et
il a jamais été considéré comme fou pour
autant donc je pense que les psychiatres
arrivent à déterminer s'il y a une
maladie mentale ou pas